[Music]
hello everyone welcome to my podcast I
am on lion and I'm going to talk today
for bullying in
school Welcome to our special podcast on
bullying in schools today we are going
to talk about what bullying is how it
affects people and what we can do all to
stop it bullying is when someone keeps
hurting another person on purpose and it
can happen in many different ways it's
important for all of us to work together
to make sure that everyone feels safe
and welcomed at school in this podcast
we'll discuss the different types of
bullying the effect it has and what we
can do to prevent it to from
happening my topic is a very delicious
topic because it has so many uh problems
all over the
world the first one is understanding
bullying bullying can happen in
different ways and it's important for us
to recognize each
type there is a verbal bullying which is
when someone uses mean words to hurt
others like calling names or teasing
then there is a physical bullying which
is when someone uses their body to hurt
others people like hitting or pushing
social bullying is when someone tries to
hurt another person's feeling or
relationships like spreading rumors or
leaving someone out on purpose cyper
bullying is when Bullying happens online
like sending mean messages or spreading
embarrassing
pictures any kind of bullying is not
okay and can hurt a lot we have another
one of effects of bullying bullying
doesn't just make people feel sad for a
short time it can have a long-term
effects on their
lives people who are bullied often feel
sad scared or
alone they might have a hard time
focusing on their school workor and
might not want go to school at all but
buing can also make people feel less
confident and make it hard for them to
trust others sometimes it can even lead
to mental health problems like anxiety
or
depression bullying doesn't just hurt
the person that is being bullied but it
can also hurt everyone around them
too another one is understanding the
bully when we talk about bullying it's
not just about the person being bullied
it's also important to understand why
someone might choose to bully
others sometimes bullies might be going
through a tough
time themselves and don't know how to
deal with their feelings in a good way
they might have seen others behave this
way and think it is okay some bullies
might feel like they need to be in
control to feel better about
themselves understanding the reasons
behind the behavior is important to find
the right Solutions and help everyone
involves we have signs of bullings here
it's important to know the signs of
bullying so we can stop it before it can
get worse if you see someone getting
hurt often having unexplained injuries
or suddenly not want to go to school
they might be experiencing bully
sometimes they might seem really sad
angry or anxious for no clear reason we
don't know about them nothing they might
also not want to talk about what's going
on paying attention to any changes in
Behavior or mood can help us understand
if someone one is going through a tough
time because of
bullying preventive measures preventing
bullying is something we can all work on
together we can start by teaching
everyone about kindness and respect it's
important to have clear rules against
bullying and to make sure every know
everyone knows what these rules are the
rules should be like bullying should get
punished bullies should get punished so
bad creating an open and trusting
environment where everyone feels
comfortable talking about their feelings
is important too by promoting
understanding and empathy we can create
a place where bullying is not
okay support for victims supporting
those who have been bullied is really
important to help them feel safe and
valued again we can provide them with a
space with a safe space to talk about
their feelings without feeling judged
they can talk free all the time and not
being judged by
someone offering celling services and
involing involving their families in
this process can help them feel
supported and understood every parent
should be involved in this process so
they can help them it's also important
to show them that they are not alone and
that there are people who care about
them by building a strong super system
we can help the victims of bullying not
just regain but feeling safe and great
in their
lives or confident and feel strong again
that they were before that empowering
bystanders bystanders are some people or
people who see bullying happening but
don't do anything about it that can play
a big role in stopping bullying so my
messages if you see if you see a bully
happening don't be a bystander but help
them or report them by teaching
bystanders how to stand up for others
and Report bullying when they see it we
can create a community where everyone
looks out for each other encouraging
them to be kind and inclusive and
showing them that they have the power to
make a difference can help a create a
safer and more caring environment for
everyone my conclusion conclusion for
bullying is a serious problem that
affects the lives of many people
by understanding bullying is why it
happens and how it affects everyone
involved we can work together to prevent
it from happening and create a safe and
supportive environmental environment for
all by promoting kindness respect and
empathy we can build a community where
every child feels valued and accepted
it's up to all of us to make sure that
our schools or places where everyone can
learn and grow without fear of being Hur
or left out together we can make a
difference create a brighter future for
everyone thank you for listening to my
podcast bye-bye from me on the lion